wilson it's public reputation has taken
a serious hit you know this following
the slapper around the world at this
year's academy awards
yeah will may be feeling more pain than
chris rock right about now i didn't
write that according to q scores
published by the variety intelligence
platform will's popularity has greatly
declined in the past four months now for
those who don't know q scored are
industry standard quantifiers for a
celebrity's star power and appeal yes
the publication states that will
regularly rank among the top five or top
10 in the united states alongside other
level boasted labs like tom hanks and
denzel washington however in the
aftermath of the oscars will's positive
q score dropped from 39 to 24. it's kind
of interesting how scientific this is so
the executive vp of q scores called this
a very significant decline while also
noting his rankings are not as bad as
other celebrities who have experienced
their own controversies citing tiger
woods
meanwhile chris rock was not negatively
impacted his scores remained at 20 and
14. okay so you and i we are not really
that surprised no right like even if
even if you didn't know the numbers here
that quantify this like you are aware
that this is happening like this is
what's been going on what's been very
interesting about um
seeing chris rock operate uh in the last
few months has been
how apparent it is like that his peers
are on his side
like comedians that are taking chris
rock's side that are publicly you know
making jokes about the situation but in
chris rock's favor
um yeah
we discussed this a little while ago but
we talked about what is it going to take
to get will back will he come back it's
not going to be the same way as it was
do people want him to be back the way
that it was like it's interesting yeah
it is really interesting and you know i
think the reason you know when we talk
about this on this show or you talk
about it amongst your friends or
co-workers it's still so shocking just
because will smith was this kind of
perfect guy in our eyes he was funny he
has the family guy
we just never even imagined there was
this side to him and you know whether it
was a mistake or you know in the moment
it was just so shocking right so
i don't know you know the question we're
asking people is do you think he will
rebound from this you and i spoke about
this a bit earlier sure we can see him
doing projects in the future yeah but
you know time has gone by and he did
recently come out with that public
apology yeah now i think a lot of people
wanted a sit-down interview i think a
lot of people would have liked to have
heard from chris rock and him i would
have personally liked that i'm still
waiting for the oprah interview with
those two but
even the backlash he got from that
yeah you know this is still very fresh
in people's minds and i i'm it's i just
don't think it's ever going to be the
same it's tough like as you said and
yeah man we've been talked about this
right so so much so much but it's that
sort of uh someone who you held in such
high regard it right who you know some
people have patterned their the way that
they are is patterned after the image of
what this of what this guy is which is
which was against disappointing but
again there are people who and you know
this is this is their stance and this is
what they believe and that's that's fine
too but who
take well side and say you know this is
deeper than what everybody sees yeah
again and i know those people i know
even the people that feel like oh man
like i can't believe that he did that
a lot of people do
want better for him if that makes sense
like want to see him i agree back in a
in a light that we go yeah okay you're
winning okay yeah you're doing better
than you were doing before
not just publicly but inside yeah i i
understand that nicole's saying he has
plenty of money if he never works again
so i find it hard to care if he bounces
back linda's saying hey no excuse for
violence uh will needs to learn that
it's not okay to do what he did
uh syphilis saying that's karma
uh
stan city is saying uh you can't cancel
a guy like will he will 100 percent
rebound from them to be fair we're
talking about the q scores too
uh negative 123. for you for me no just
i don't even not on the case
you're not connecting with people
never mind the q score the rst uv score
i'm somewhere down there somewhere i'm
not even looking i don't even want to
know my score i don't know